[Music]
this program is sponsored by the kavli
prize
which honors scientists for
breakthroughs in astrophysics
nanoscience and neuroscience that
transform
our understanding of the very big the
very small
and the very complex
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't mind i'd like to exchange my
straight jacket for something in a 39
[Music]
north
[Music]
and there's a mysterious force out there
in space that literally comes out of
nowhere
it's a force that seems to be pushing
the universe apart
[Music]
[Music]
i found a microscopic needle in a 10-ton
haystack
[Music]
there's a way through communication to
bring the beauty of science to the rest
of the world
millions of people from around the world
know alan alda from as well as hawkeye
pierce in mash one of the most popular
television series of
all time what is it that makes us human
but those who are science enthusiasts
know alan
from a different perspective they know
him as a man who has worked
tirelessly to popularize science to
improve
how it is communicated and later on in
this program the kavi foundation will
honor his achievements
in that arena those achievements
have been extraordinary as has been his
life
and with that i am thrilled to welcome
alan alda
thank you brian hi alan how are you
doing i'm
doing great it's great to be talking to
you even virtually
it's not every day that you come across
a picture of a serious
pipe-smoking two-year-old and that was
the point
allen's father used the picture to
publicize one of his shows
robert alda knew how to capture
attention
and pass that gift on to his son i was
born when my father was a
singer and straight man in burlesque i
had these vivid memories from the time i
was
two two and a half standing in the wings
watching the
burlesque comics the chorus girls the
strippers
i got a real education in theater i
actually i got a very broad education
when you think about it
that introduced me to show business to
communicating through
that that particular art but i was
always curious i can remember as i grew
up i was very curious about how things
worked and all my life i've
i've read about science but never
studied it formally did people encourage
you
in that i mean in the community that
you're within did people looking and say
like
why why are you talking the science
stuff you know your your
your impact is in in the arts was there
any kind of resistance
or is it encouraged no but you know i
fell under the sway
of the uh of what cp snow was talking
about
in the 50s in 1959 the british
intellectual cp
snow published a much discussed essay in
which he argued that
two distinct cultures had arisen one
devoted to science
and the other to the arts when i was in
high school
that's around the time he was writing
that
and i thought i had to choose between an
interest in science
and an interest in the arts and i
quieted down on on my interest in
science and it wasn't till i was
maybe in my early 20s that i began to
read scientific american
avidly and i realized there was a whole
other way of thinking
not the difference between art and
science but the difference between
non-science and science because art and
science
have a lot of similarities i think you i
think you agree with that
yeah no i totally do each is searching
for a kind of truth they're just
undertaking the search in in different
and complementary ways is how i see it
and they're both rigorous yeah you know
it
seems that you you have a lot more
latitude and art but not every word will
do
in a poem not every note will do in a
symphony
and in a performance it can go
sour with the slightest mis
mis-speaking mis misinterpretation
and that that is a different kind of
rigor but it's also rigor
the rigor allen applied to his art
proved to be enormously successful
he starred in mash whose finale still
holds the record for being the most
watched television episode in american
history
and i can't say that i've loved you all
either but i've loved as many of you as
i could
on mash aland earned emmys for acting
writing and directing
the paths he could pursue were endless
but one opportunity stood out among the
rest
hi i'm alan alder about to launch what
promises to be a challenging new
adventure as host of scientific american
frontiers
despite the energy allen had put into
his artistic career
his passion for science never abated
and scientific american frontiers
offered the opportunity to combine that
passion with his experience on
television
getting to know the people behind the
science was a particular enticement
i thought this is great i have a chance
to interview them i said i only wanted
to do it if i could
talk to them on camera so i could spend
the day with them and find out about
their work
what were your childhood dreams what
what do you mean by that i remember some
books
a book i was reading as a child was a
picture book and it had this allen
hosted scientific american frontiers on
pbs for
11 seasons giving free reign to his
unquenchable
interest in science this device this
satellite
is picking up this
cosmic background microwave radiation
from way back
in time right right from the beginning
of
the universe it's actually a direct
picture of what the universe used to be
like because it took that light
all that time to get from there to the
satellite scientific
american frontiers allowed allen to
report on basic science
philosophical questions and cutting-edge
technology
that's dan kemp on the table in there
army veteran quadriplegic
and as i think you'll see a remarkable
person
dan is one of the people we'll be
meeting in our first story which is
about
something that scientists have been
trying to do for at least 200 years to
control
and manipulate the human body using
electricity
allen with so many interviews having
spoken with so many people
during the time you were host of
scientific american frontiers
any of those encounters that really
stand
out as as the most memorable of all you
know i'm very fond of the producers of
that show but they were trying to kill
me for 11 years
for instance in one show the producer
said to me
we have to climb up to the top of mount
vesuvius
i said why do we have to do that she
said well there's a scientist up there
with equipment and she's monitoring the
volcano i said i don't think we should
march up to the
tip of a volcano he said why not is it
because the program we're doing is about
how it could blow at any moment
he said don't worry that she has all
this equipment it tells her everything
so we walk all the way up to the top and
i sit down next to her
this is the crater of the last eruption
of vesuvius
and i said so how much does your
equipment tell you
she says oh not too much are you want to
do pull-ups oh
good but the most memorable experiences
i've had i think are with animals
we were dealing with baby chimps who had
been brought up in captivity and they
had to be trained
how to live in the wild so they were
training them to
to do that so i i sat down next to this
cute little guy he looked like
a two-year-old human
[Laughter]
and i said hello to him and i was
speaking nicely to him and he reached up
and gave me such a sock in the puss
oh ouch
ouch and then he held out his hand like
this but now he's saying i'm sorry
that's apparently a gesture they make to
tell you they're sorry i said never mind
the excuse how about not doing it
and i'm keeping track of how you're
thinking i was having a nice
conversation with a scientist called
brian hare
and he was telling me about chimps and
in the middle of the conversation
by a plate of glass next to where the
chimps were living
and i don't know what it was about this
huge chimp he must have weighed 800
pounds
while we were talking it came just came
by and they're political
he just slammed against the glass like
i'm i'm in charge here not you
they all had that little uh attitude
with me it's doing what
it's buying it's biting the boat and
then they made me
work with a shark you went into the
water with shark
we caught an eight-foot shark in an
11-foot row boat
oh boy that's like oh now i'm playing
the part of richard dreyfuss
oh is he busy today during his 11
seasons on scientific american frontiers
allen interviewed hundreds of scientists
about their work
but one scientist in particular had an
unexpected
and enduring impact we were having a
very good connection
something i said reminded her of the
lecture she gave
and she she had been talking to me and
she turned away from me and looked
straight at the camera and started
telling the camera
her lecture so i i coaxed her back with
some questions and she came back to me
and when she came back to me her tone
was completely different
it was personal and connected but then
something reminded her of the lecture
and she turned back to the camera again
and the tone got cold
and lecturish she was in lecture mode
i realized something really important in
that moment how important it was to
maintain that contact
and and how i could develop ways of
getting them back into
into into that intimate connection well
look we as scientists
you know were trained throughout most of
our
undergraduate graduate education
to strip away all the human elements
of communication in order that the
papers that we
write have utter precision and of course
natural language when you're just
talking back and forth
there's an interpretation there's
emotion there's qualities that
shade meaning and we're trained to kind
of get rid of all that stuff in order
that there's precision in the literature
and so and so i totally understand how
it can be that a scientist would turn
in the midst of a conversation and lock
back into the
mode of discourse that we're trained but
presumably this must underlie
the approach that you've developed to
try to help scientists to
to kind of step outside the more
traditional scientific training and and
communicate as human beings that's right
so i thought as the show was ending
wouldn't it be a good idea if we could
train
scientists to make this connection
with an audience without the need of
somebody like me standing there
helping them connect and what if we did
it by teaching them the same way i
learned which was through starting with
improvisation
allen did some improvising of his own
devising an impromptu experiment with
20 engineering students at usc as proof
of concept
so when they came in i asked them to
talk about their work for
two minutes each one to talk to the
other 19.
and they were a little locked into
lecture mode
then we improvised for two hours and i
asked them to talk again
[Music]
and it was amazing allen was now
convinced that
training scientists in improv would
vastly improve their communication
skills
but his proposals to train them in an
academic setting were met with
skepticism
until stony brook university signed on
the reason we talked so much about and
do so much
improvising is that
we've come to see that it's foundational
that there's something about the
experience of improvising that opens you
up to another person
when we started up i began working with
a group of scientists from stony brook
and we did six
weeks of training and
learned about lungs
when she left she's not laughing
communication is a two-way street if
it's only one way if it's just me
telling you what i think i know i'm
spraying
information at you but i want to get you
engaged i want you to hear it i want you
to remember
and what's so interesting is the
scientists
took to the improv exercises and games
with as much enthusiasm as actors do
they gave themselves over to
[Music]
and you find that those exercises then
inform the way that they present
science in a more ordinary setting not
not in the class yeah yeah here's the
thing it may look
silly to some people to see people
mirroring each other moving their
arms together or carrying a piece of
plate glass
but the experience of making contact
through these improv exercises gets you
habituated
to looking the other person in the eye
to picking up on their facial
expressions to sensing something about
their tone of voice that communicates
something to you that actually has an
effect on you and
changes you in some way makes you
respond in a certain way
good evening as an alumna of saturday
night live
and chicago's famed second city
improvisational troupe
tina fey is one of the country's most
skilled practitioners of improv
one of the core ideas in improvisation
is is
to agree to say yes and right to agree
is the yes and then the and is to
contribute something
of your own and it's something that once
you get in the habit of doing it as an
improviser i don't know if you
find the same thing that i it's just the
way you think about things and
always um shocked when i uh if you meet
someone in a work situation or someone
who who's starting from a place of no
like well i don't think we're going to
be able to do that right you're just
like oh why would you
why would you start there and at the
world science festival
tina and alan joined forces to deliver
an essential message
tina is my mirror and i'm looking into
the mirror and she has to be
a true mirror instantaneously doing what
i'm doing as if she were a real mirror
there has to be no lag time
if i do that she can't follow me and
this is the most
interesting thing for scientists to
understand or anybody
who's learning better communication from
this exercise this is fundamental
if i do this she can't be my mirror it's
my
job to help her follow me so if i'm
communicating to you and i want you to
understand something and you don't
follow me
i'm not helping you follow me and back
at stony brook university
these ideas are taking root among the
scientists
allen teaches the mirror exercise that's
a really great
there are so many great key ideas and
concepts in there
i can foresee you know sharing bad news
and in that context you don't want to
just lay the news on someone on the
patient without
you really want to be very attuned to
their reaction and you know that back
and forth is so crucial
allen's efforts to improve science
communication
are aimed at making science more
accessible
especially to kids why is
and harder than it sounds i love the
questions that are harder than they
sound
when i was 11 years old i was fascinated
with with flame
i didn't know what it was so i asked a
teacher
i said what what's what's a flame
and she thought for a second and said
oxidation
now i had two things i didn't know the
answer to
but decades later in an article for
science magazine
allen raised the question again so i
said to the scientists
at the end of that article how about a
little contest
where you explain to 11 year olds what a
flame is
in ways that will engage them
and help them understand and the judges
of the contest will be real 11 year olds
ellie's going to give the trophy to the
winner
of the 2012 world science festival
flame challenge to ben ames
they're names come on up then
and this is how ben answered the
question that allen posed to his
teachers
years earlier everything is made up of
billions and
billions of atoms now this candle and
flame well they are made up of three
kinds of atoms
carbon hydrogen and oxygen
the carbon and the hydrogen are locked
together to form a solid wax and wick
the oxygen is a gas all around us
normally the oxygen doesn't do much to
the candle
it just bounces off of the surface not
doing any real damage
but when we add heat the oxygen atoms go
bananas
and they shake the wax like crazy until
finally with enough force
they snap apart they leave the candle as
a gas
where they mix with the oxygen uh-oh i
smell trouble
and it turned out to be such a wonderful
thing i mean we got a lot of scientists
joining in and we did it for several
years welcome to
what is sleep which of course grew out
of the flame challenge
thanks so much thanks for coming so the
flame challenge
this year has the question what is time
this year's question what is sound has
been answered by scientists
all around the world the kids were
wonderful
the kids were able to say they were in a
power of
strength you know a power of dignity
with regard to these
fancy scientists they could say to them
you know
that explanation was very good but it
could be better
what i enjoyed most about the flame
challenge was just
learning how flames are started like
with the atoms and stuff
and i also like to hear different
perspectives from all the scientists
around the world
and the scientists would try to get
their attention by being funny and
sometimes silly
and the kid was one kid who was great he
said you know
it's one thing to be funny but you don't
have to be silly we're 11 we're not
seven hello
[Applause]
alan hosts panels at the world science
festival on a wide range of topics
beyond the flame challenge what if you
could
actually read another person's mind
brain science has reached the point now
and or is reaching it
where they have made amazing advances
in the ability to see what's going on in
someone else's mind
the question is do you think that
there's something
fundamental missing in the
in the notion of quantum physics what is
it
about altruism that's such a problem
how could it have threatened the theory
of evolution
alan at the world science festival you
have done
a heroic job of of hosting so many
programs on such a wide range of
sciences which has always
made me wonder you know you know is
there some
area of science that that you most enjoy
having
these on stage conversations or
demonstrations about
you know i love physics so much i love
i'm
i love the mystery of physics einstein's
lab time warp
says that uh everything likes to
live where it's going to age most slowly
and gravity pulls it there
and so you age more slowly if you're on
the surface of the earth than if you're
at high altitude
when it's a biologist i love the biology
we have the longest childhood of any any
primate right eight
probably absolutely it takes 13 million
calories
to rear a human from birth to
nutritional
independence and i was through with them
in the first year
allen has had extraordinary success as
an actor
writer producer and as a teacher of
science communication
and those skills converge in the
theatrical productions he has written or
produced
about scientists
[Music]
i don't know if you remember but you
called me
because you're playing richard feynman
in qed
uh this wonderful play about the
physicist richard feynman and you were
doing it out in
in los angeles i think it was and you
called me up out of the blue
and said i have to say all these physics
words in this show
i'd like to know what in the world they
mean and you and i discussed you know
quantum electrodynamics and the
motion of photons reflecting off of
glass and so forth and then you invited
me out
to see the final performance in la so i
flew out and saw it
and then we went out to dinner
afterwards and i figured we would just
be chit-chatting about stuff
we stayed at the restaurant until like
two in the morning the waiters wanted to
kick us out
because you were continually asking me
more and more
questions about the physics and it
struck me as so
wonderful and and unexpected because
your run as richard feynman was over you
didn't need to know
the stuff for the the show anymore so
it's just to say that it's such a
genuine
passion for for science
you know and you discussed how sort of
that came from you know
over the years you know being enamored
with some of these ideas
but but this presumably is
something you are as passionate about as
as you are about the other things that
you've done in your life
i am and and it's because to me it's
it's the world's greatest detective
story it's
it's also the greatest poetry the way
you folks have figured out how nature
fits together it's various parts
some of the parts that don't fit
together like the big world and the tiny
tiny small world
so i i'm afraid that every time we meet
for dinner you and i
you you're home putting on your jacket
saying i hope he doesn't ask me about
physics again tonight
not at all not at all so that passion
has also translated into other things
that you've done
right you you've written plays about
some of the great scientists dear albert
where you took
the correspondence of albert einstein
and and
melded it all together into a wonderful
onstage experience
of albert einstein a radiance you you
wrote about
marie curie what was it about those
characters in particular
that pulled you in to the point that you
would
create these on stage works about them
well i love the story of marie
curie she she's my hero nothing stood in
her
way and when things went against her
she didn't give up she was
she was a powerhouse i i don't
understand is there something about
being a woman
that requires invisibility
and i really love that about her and i
decided to write a play about her
and i was going to try to find all her
letters and base it on her letters
and then i found out that every piece of
paper she had come in contact with was
still radioactive
so i switched to einstein
so the the the einstein letters
were not radioactive but full of juice
albert
himself is refusing to take any decision
he is prepared to marry either me or
mama
then i went back to marie because i
realized i could tell her story without
actually touching her papers although i
went into her
lab in paris and her lab has been
turned into a place that you can visit
however
there's a piece of paper from her
notebook
from the day she discovered
radium and it's behind a glass
frame so the curator of the place
opened up the frame on a hinge
and held the geiger counter up to the
page
and it clicked like a tap dancer really
yeah so i took a step back from that
understandably but i i i loved
tracing her steps in paris i walked as
fast as i could from her
her lab to the place where she
met her lover to see how out of breath
she'd be when she came in the room in
the play
she's brought formal charges against me
the police are investigating they have
the letters
it's a criminal charge what marie picks
up a newspaper marie
consorting with a concubine in the
marital dwelling
concubine apparently it's a crop well
first of all i'm not a concubine and
secondly we never consorted
in a marital twist yes well by the time
that's established our lives will be
destroyed
that's all she cares about now the
letters will probably be presented in
evidence and you'll probably have to
give testimony
this trial is set for december 8th yes
that's when i'm supposed to be in
stockholm receiving the nobel prize yes
please put the paper down marie it was
really fun
i mean the fact that both einstein and
marie curie both had
how can one put it fairly messy
personal lives in some sense at least as
viewed from the outside viewed from the
public was that
an appealing aspect of both of these
characters
yeah very much so for me because
to me it's very important that we
understand that scientists are human
and one way to convince an audience that
a great scientist wasn't just a
fountainhead of greatness
but was also a person like them is to
let the story reveal
some of the tragic mistakes they made in
their lives
einstein was kind of cruel to his first
wife
and a little bit infatuated with himself
and
with regard to most women dear elsa
do you think it is so easy to get a
divorce if one does not have any proof
of the other party's guilt
on the other hand i treat my wife as an
employee whom i cannot fire
so have you seen you know actors and
directors those who are
you know from the arts community get
excited about the stories of science
boy they sure were when when i asked
actors to play in these plays that
i wrote about marie curie and einstein
they were so enthusiastic
and some of them came with a good
background
basic understanding of of some of the
science
and all of them wanted to know more why
do you torment me so endlessly
they were all enthusiastic about it when
i asked paul rudd
if he would please play einstein and i
know how busy he is and i
was giving him reasons why he might have
fun and it would be a good thing to do
he said you had me at mc squared
explaining einstein's most famous
equation can be a daunting task
but understanding the science as well as
the scientist
is fundamental for alan we thought it
would be fun
to spend a few minutes just a few
minutes
um brian green and i having a little
conversation
about mostly about the science behind
what was uh happening in in his life and
whether he's expressing curiosity
wonder or skepticism alan is always the
audience's most effective
and relatable surrogate in any situation
where there's gravity if you don't want
to have to deal with it directly
just execute a certain kind of motion
jump out a window
and then gravity goes away
what
you jump out the window gravity makes a
quick entrance
now i can show you this thing when i
take off this cap
air pressure is going to be entering
into the bottle
and water is going to spew out a few
holes that i have here because gravity
is going to pull down
on the water and then what i'm going to
do is i'm going to let the bottle go
into free fall
and watch that the water won't spray out
any longer
right so that's what you should look for
okay here we go
all right right so here goes the water
oh oh sorry about that right
so um now watch when i let it go
holy moly right one more time gravity
goes away
right see there it is it's not just the
audiences that find alan relatable
so do the scientists we are really no
longer in the realm
of observations of good answers
we are really at the stage where we
should ask good questions
and i think there's nobody better to ask
these questions
than elenola
[Music]
having achieved enormous success as a
communicator in traditional media
allen now has his sights set on
communication
in the digital world you know one of the
things i've noticed about you through
the years
is you're very forward thinking when it
comes to
technology and and the way that
technology can
change the way we communicate i remember
when i first got my uh
my first iphone i don't know it's like
the iphone one you're up to the iphone a
million
at that point you were so far ahead of
me we actually had a conversation where
you said to me
what apps do you have and i was
embarrassed that i did not know
what an app was at that moment so i just
kind of mumbled something and turned
away
so you're also right now at the cutting
edge
of this you know explosion of podcasts
where you have clear and vivid i i've
had the honor of being on your program
welcome to clear and vivid this is the
first in a series of live web shows
where we'll be talking about the latest
ideas
in both science communication and health
communication
so what motivated you to embrace this
this new approach to getting ideas out
there
well partly it's another way for me to
talk to smart people not only about
science but about
pretty much every subject as long as it
relates in some way to communication and
relating
and i've talked to such a wonderful
bunch of people
there are 120 or 130 podcasts now i've
done
it's interesting with the podcast i'm
often talking to somebody who's a nobel
prize winner
or a great artist
and i might have 10 things that i'm
curious about
that i want to find out from them but i
don't have specific
questions first of all it's so
interesting that bacteria
evolved the ability to fend off a virus
these little guys had this
sophisticated tool to do it
how did you how did you figure out
that that would somehow be useful to
humans
well let's go back to where where this
all began
because it really started with a few
microbiologists
people that study bacteria wondering how
it is
that bacteria are able to defend
themselves from viruses
whatever they say to me lights me up
makes me want to know more
and you can rely more on that than you
can on a stiff
formalized set of questions what do you
wish you
really understood
i really wish i understood human
behavior i think i'd be a much better
person
a much better leader i definitely would
have been a much better wife
[Laughter]
[Music]
though alan has explored the cutting
edge of science for decades
it's his home life that keeps him
grounded he's been married for 63 years
to the musician
author and photographer arlene alda
he is a father and a grandfather who
relishes
both of those roles
and when allen prepares for a science
panel
his kids are happy to help out
hello thank you you know i was at my
computer this morning
um trying to get up to speed for tonight
and an email popped up on my screen from
my daughter reeve
and and and and and it required a long
answer and i said i
just shot back and answered quickly and
i said i i can't answer you right now
i'm
i'm i'm trying to learn everything that
is known about black holes in the next
two hours
so uh being my daughter she shot back an
answer to me
and she said you need the whole two
hours
so then she like laid it out for me one
there are areas of space that suck
everything into them
two you don't want to get near a black
hole
three some people are like black holes
they suck everyone around them into
their vortex
allen's life is not without its
challenges
on a remote mountain in chile he faced a
life-threatening
medical emergency he slid me in the
ambulance i'm screaming and painting me
an hour and a half down a bumpy mountain
road
to this little hospital where there's
this brilliant surgeon who knew
exactly what was wrong with me it wasn't
my appendix at all
was about a yard of my intestine that
had been all crimped up and lost its
blood supply
and within a couple of hours it was
going to be dead and so was i
but this was the communication this was
so wonderful
he leaned over so he could see my face
and i could see his face and i could
still see his
his eyes through his rimless glasses
and he said here's what's happened
some of your intestine has gone bad and
we have to cut out the bad part
and sew the two good ends together
and i said oh you're going to do an
end-to-end anastomosis
he said how do you know that i said oh i
did many of them on mash
[Laughter]
but whatever challenges allen faces he
does so with the grace
and optimism his fans have come to love
i haven't said in public until now that
i've been diagnosed with parkinson's
disease and the reason that i want to
talk about it in public
is that it's i was diagnosed three and a
half years ago
and i've had a full life since then so
you've also been quite
public you know with the news of your
own
diagnosis with parkinson's uh
how has that changed your outlook has
has it had an
impact on the way you you the work that
you do
and and the outlook that you have
no i not much well i don't i'm getting
i'm
pretty soon going to be at the point
where i probably will only play people
with parkinson's
as an actor but
the podcast is still open to me and i
love it i have as much fun doing that as
i do acting
writing is still open to me although
when i write
dr parkinson hits keys that i don't want
him to
so it's a collaboration between me and
the good doctor
the joy alan takes in learning about
science and the efforts he has made to
make science accessible
have earned him the respect and
admiration of scientists around the
world
and that is particularly true of the
scientists who run
the kavli foundation today bob khan
the foundation's recently retired
president is here to make
a very special announcement thanks brian
and great to see you how are you alan
wonderful to see you virtually in person
so to speak
i'm great thank you uh alan
and you've been a constant partner with
us you've co-hosted the cavity prize
ceremony in oslo since 2010.
once again it's a pleasure to welcome
you to this great
ceremony you've allowed us to partner
with you for a decade or more as you
built the all the center for
communicating science
helping scientists better communicate
what they do
helping connect society with the joys of
science
and as a scientist i can tell you it is
a joy
and while we can add numerous examples i
just want to say this
we share a common belief with you in the
societal benefits
derive from curiosity driven basic
scientific research
and we're all the beneficiaries from
your commitment
to that message so for your
immeasurable contributions to science
and science communications
the cavalry foundation is honored to
present to you
the first ever distinguished cavity
science
communicator medal and i want to hold it
up here
so you can see it
it looks just like the many cavity prize
medals you've seen in oslo
but it's dedicated to you as a special
medal
for all the work you have done that's
amazing
thank you the support you've given the
alda center
over the last 10 years the advice you've
given us the
encouragement the funding
has helped us enable the amazing staff
and teaching staff
at the alder center to train scientists
all over the world
that that would have been enough ganug
but you've you've topped it now and
and this will be such an honor that goes
to the people who make the oldest center
so brilliant
and i'm so grateful and i'm grateful for
your help
with clear and vivid and science clear
and vivid
two podcasts that we've been working on
together
it's just great the hopley foundation
has done so much good in the world
and i'm i'm really honored to be among
the people who have
benefited from your insight and your
intelligence and your forward-looking
programs thank you so much bub
oh you're most welcome alan uh we
couldn't be more pleased
that you're the first recipient of this
special kind of
recognition so um maybe i'll say
thanks to brian and alan it's been great
to see you again
and i'll see you soon see you soon bob
thank you so much
so alan congratulations how do you feel
about this award
oh i i i think stunned is the word
wow you know one of your other uh
subjects in the podcast
was you know what makes people happy
and so so you know natural question is
just turn it back
to you when you think about all the
things that you've done
throughout your life and you imagine the
things that you're still going to do
going forward
what does give you the greatest sense of
happiness
i don't know it's hard to say what the
greatest sense of happiness is
for me but i do know there are things
that make me very happy and very content
one is to do what i know how to do well
that makes me feel really good and
along those lines to learn how to do it
better
feels even better seeing the
relationships i have
the love i have with my wife my children
my grandchildren
to see that working to see us making the
kind of connection we talked about at
the beginning of our conversation
effortlessly makes me very happy
makes me happy to be able to deal with
reality
in the marie curie play i wrote
marie says something that i
wrote for her she didn't say it in real
life
but when the person who loves her
when it's not working and she has to let
him go
and he can't take it and she says
but reality as it turns out is something
else i can't accept this
i won't it's just reality paul
paul it's just reality
[Music]
i operate on that idea reality
is our friend that's one of the reasons
i'm so
enthralled by science because the more i
can understand about the reality of
nature
the more comfortable i'll be and i know
that part of the reality is i'll never
know everything
no humanity will never know everything
so i'm not hoping for a conclusion
to this search but i can i love the
reality of the fact that in spite of the
fact that we're never going to get there
we keep searching that's us and that's
fun well you certainly have
over the course of many years enhance
the reality
of many people those who have enjoyed
watching you in television and in film
on the stage and those of us in science
who have certainly enjoyed all of those
activities but so greatly appreciate
what you have done to elevate the
discourse
in the field so i thank you for all of
those activities
i congratulate you on this prize from
the cobley
foundation and i thank you so much for
joining us today
thank you
what's playing on pbs i'll tell you
what's playing on pbs
science show hosted by a guy who won't
allow the use of obfuscational
terminology that sounds like it
otherwise might be
bs that's what's playing on pbs
what's happening at stony brook i'll
tell you what's happening at stony brook
improvisational acting for young
scientists for when they talk about what
they're doing they don't use inscrutable
words or even so much as a phony look
that's what's happening at stony brook
what's going on at the gala i'll tell
you what's going on at the gala
guy being honored for making sure that
scientific concepts get communicated
clearly even though he has a voice that
sounds something like a sailor
that's what's going on at the gala
science is the thing that
he holds dear oh and that's why
alan is our hero
yes it's good old insatiable
and alan alda's got the right stuff
if a smarty pen starts using jargon and
guff
although's there to clarify by calling
his bluff yes it's good old insatiable
and he's going from here to bangkok
as the oldest respected science
explaining
nice guy in new york
there are complex concepts everywhere
everywhere
there are complex concepts everywhere
yeah but knowledge sources all day is
for every guy and don't share
oh no